the next theory then Jon Snow is alive
this is probably completely obvious but
this is how I think Jon Snow is going to
be alive everyone thinks that he's going
to walk out I mean it's well known that
the stark children can walk we've seen
are you do it with Nymeria Brown
obviously is a famous example he walks
into summer all the time and he can even
walk into Hodor as a brand swatted like
the strongest walk but Jon Snow can do
it too so this is me this is a much
bigger deal i think in the book he has
dreams where he walks into ghosts and he
does it when they are scouting north of
the wall when they're looking for wild
wings and things so to me it's a big
deal so he can do it but the thing is I
don't think that'll happen if he decides
to walk out into ghosts at the last
minute before he dies then like the
actor of Kit Harington will be gone and
if he has a claim to the throne that'll
you know just be lost on a dog so I
don't think that's gonna happen although
that dog will probably become like the
highest-paid dog in television history
but no I think this other option is more
likely and that is Melisandre bringing
John back from the dead so Melisandre
basically clung on to Stannis Baratheon
because she believed that he was this
legendary warrior of light Azure a high
reborn as or a high managed to like take
on all the others like the White Walkers
like the last time they tried to come
down into Westeros you know as a
prophecy there's good that he's gonna be
reborn and Melisandre thought that was
going to be Stannis and it's kind of
obvious that not Stannis like nothing
went right for that poor guy so the
other option could be that it's jon snow
she's a priestess of the Lord of Light
and we know that in their religion like
that magic exists like they can bring
people back from the dead like Thoris of
Maya brought back beric Dondarrion Lady
Stoneheart like we know it can happen so
the highly likely the Melisandre and
Davos Seaworth are going to work
together to get Jon Snow's body and
bring him back from the dead there's a
line from a dance of dragons that a lot
of people have read a lot into I pray
for a glimpse of azure a high what role
are only shows me snow jon snow or the
white stuff you decide but I think it's
war floppy-haired job
you